estos son los hogares de California
después de que una serie de implacables
tormentas las azotaron desde el
principio de año
ráfagas de Viento y precipitaciones
récord han provocado corrimientos de
tierra y caídas de árboles inundando
polos enteros y dejando a miles de
hogares sin electricidad
es mucho peor de lo esperado todas mis
ventanas de la parte de atrás están
completamente reventadas todas mis mesas
están desparramadas por el suelo y
obviamente arruinadas y nuestros suelos
se han deformado
Todos Los Arroyos se desbordaron y había
rocas en el barro fue realmente horrible
tuvieron que sacar a la gente en
helicópteros fue realmente devastador
ver tu ciudad y este nivel de
destrucción
este puente en el este de Sacramento
está bajo el agua y podría permanecer
sumergidos y los niveles siguen subiendo
en la costa de Río del mar una mujer
llena frenéticamente sacos de arena para
evitar que el agua se filtre en su casa
las carreteras de montecito hogar de
estrellas de Hollywood también han
quedado cubiertas de barro
el gobernador de California advierte que
se avecinan más tormentas y ríos
atmosféricos
Esperamos que estas tormentas continúen
al menos hasta el 18 de este mes
esperamos un mínimo de tres más de estos
ríos atmosféricos en diferentes formas
dependiendo de las diferentes partes del
estado
más de la mitad de los 58 condados de
California han sido declarados como
zonas de desastre con los servicios de
emergencia estimando que el coste de
daños supera los mil millones de dólares